My book,
the psychopath and site is a memoir and
it's a mix of a personal story and what
the science is that it's the psychiatry
and the genetics and the neuroscience
behind what the subject is,
which is psychopathy,
but it's really a story about somebody
me who had 60 finds out.
He's not really who he thought he was
all along in his whole life and not
until I had,
just by serendipity,
by chance started to run across
biological evidence first from pet
scans,
positron emission tomography scans,
uh,
that I was involved with a acted as a
control in one study in Alzheimer's
disease and,
uh,
and also had my genetics done.
So it was just as a control and compared
to people with Alzheimer's.
And so it was through that about,
oh,
seven,
six,
seven years ago that I found out
something very strange and in,
in this something strange,
both in terms of my brain pattern.
And then genetics happened to run.
It intersected with another study.
I had been doing a minor study on
looking at pet scans and Mris.
Another kind of brain scan and SPEC
scans of,
of killers,
really bad murderers and these are
particularly bad on brays and some
serial killers,
et cetera.
And I had looked at these bananas to
analyze them over the years from the
early 19 nineties onward and in,
in about the same time,
2005 when I was doing my own scans for
the South San Study.
I had got a whole group of these killers
and a psychopath and looked at a pattern
I sent my God,
there's a pattern in the brain for these
guys.
And so I started to talk about it,
give talks and uh,
you know,
at academic institutions and psychiatry
departments,
law schools,
etc. Just to kind of vet the idea.
But at the same time I got this pile of
scans back,
uh,
that included my own and these other
controls.
And I was looking through.
I got to the last scan of that study at
the alzheimer's and I,
I looked at it and I asked my
technician,
I said,
you've got to check the machines because
this is obviously one of the killers.
So one of the murders,
it looked like a really,
like a severe case of brain activity
lost in a psychopath.
And so when I ultimately they said,
no,
this is part of,
it's in this control group.
And I had to tear back the,
uh,
the name on it because I always do
anything blind,
but this was like something's really
wrong and it turned out to be my name.
So it was like,
you know,
gandalf shows up at the door and you're
it.
And so that started this whole
traJectory.
Now,
at first I didn't think I laughed at it
and,
and I just didn't care.
We were so busy working on the genetics
of alzheimer's and also schizophrenia
and I had just started an adult stem
cell company.
And so,
so busy with stuff.
I kind of let it go for a couple of
years,
really a year and a half.
But then the genetics came back and I
had all the genetic illegals,
the forms of the genes that are
associated with the high aggression and
violence,
psychopathy and a low kind of empathy,
interpersonal,
emotional empathy and low anxiety.
and in it,
when I got that back,
I started to take a little bit of an but
it's still didn't care about it and it
wasn't until I ended up giving a talk,
I was asked to give a talk with the ex
prime minister of oslow and bipolar
disorder.
And so I went to oslo to give a puBlic
talk with him than a clinician on
bipolar,
you know,
what's the brain patterns?
And I had to use my own example of how
we,
you do imaging genetics,
we take imaging of the brain genetics,
put it together in a mathematIcal model
and how we figure it out so it can be
used for all sorts of psychiatry and
medicine and in the audience or the
psychiatrist there.
And I went through my own pathologies,
if you will,
or near clinical syndromes and my
netflix and my brain scan.
And at the end the head of the
department there said,
you don't even know this.
I bet,
but you,
you're bipolar first of all because you
don't have the kind of bipolar in the
United States that,
that they use.
What are the kinds.
So that's interesting.
And he said,
I want to talk to you afterwards.
So I met with the psychiatrist
afterwards and they said,
you're probably borderline psychopath to
looking at all this.
So.
Well,
this was kind of a real surprise.
It's a first time I took it seriously
because I had not only the biological
evidence,
but these people didn't even know me.
They were just looking at the data,
you know,
and they could see my behaviors.
And in talking to me for a couple hours
after that talk at somebody's house,
they said,
you probably do.
So when I flew back to the United
States,
uh,
what I did is I started,
I said,
I started asking the psychiatrist and
neurologist that I knew really well for
many years and who know my behaviors,
including my not so nice behaviors.
And I said,
you gotta tell me what you really think
of me.
And each one of them had said,
well,
you know,
we told you for many years,
you,
you're,
you know,
you do psychopathic things.
You're probably a borderline psychopath.
I said,
no,
no.
You said I was crazy.
That's what we never said and be crazy
and act crazy,
but you're like a borderline psychopath.
Then I asked all my close friends,
my wife,
people in my family,
and they all had the same thing to say.
And at that point
it was really kind of hit me.
I was like,
well,
this is maybe true.
And I started to take the test for
psychopathy and it came up borderline
borderline psychopath that is a very
high score,
but without being at what's called the
categorical full blown a psychopath,
which contains these anti,
a lot of antisocial and criminal parts
of it.
And since I'm not a criminal,
I've had conversations with the police
many times,
but I am always able to kind of talk my
way out of it and get them to lAugh,
you know.
And so,
uh,
but I have no record or anything,
but you know,
I've done some fun things now.
And so at that point,
and I was just sitting with these two
psychiatrists and they said,
you got all this evidence in front of
you do.
I mean,
you see what's going at.
And I'll tell you,
I didn't care,
I really didn't care at all.
And they said that's the point,
you don't care.
And so,
uh,
so that at that point,
you know,
I,
I had started to beg,
gave a ted talk and then a moth talk
world science festival and then I got
contacted by some people,
a different prime shows.
It wouldn't be on criminal minds and
things like that.
But after that I got contacted by the
same day by three literary agents in New
York and they said,
you've got to read a book on this.
But people really interested in this.
And it was personal too.
When I wrote the book,
I really met and had a heart to heart
talk with my old family.
I said,
because this is going to be,
it could be embarrassing,
you know,
for all of us.
There could be some exposure and risk,
but they were sort of a heroic about it.
I just had to count on my own narcissism
to drive it.
You're like,
I can do this,
you know,
I can beat this,
I can write this.
I am tough.
And so I kind of use some of the traits
to drive it forward.
So,
uh,
so actually coming out like this,
it also assured that I couldn't get away
with things anymore,
you know,
and when you tell people what you're
doing,
like I do in the book,
many of the things they're looking for
it.
And,
and,
and it's so it's like,
you know,
my game is up in,
in a sense,
but I'm also 66.
I'm mean,
how do I really want to be that way
anymore?
I,
you know,
uh,
I still have fun with it,
but it's,
it's just the challenge,
right?
It's,
it's a challenge and I think I can
overcome it.
So I have to use my ego and my sense of
narcissism to manipulate myself to
handled,
you know.
And um,
and,
but it was really my family that said,
go for it.
My mother is still alive.
And she'll say,
I'm,
you're saying too much.
You'd saying way too much.
And of course I said my,
you don't know what the half of it,
you know,
of course I said,
as long as you're alive and my family's
alive,
my kids,
you know,
I'm telling you know,
a piece of the story,
but I give a fair amount in the book
more than in my talks.
But I asked the psychiatrist who'd known
me as nomi for many years,
what behaviors that are not so obvious
that I do talk to people that would be
psychopathic.
And they asked me about revenge.
Am I getting even that?
Everybody gets mad,
right?
Somebody ticks you off.
You get mad.
He could make five seconds,
30 seconds,
a minute up to an rp,
everybody,
it's a normal thing.
And your serotonin kicks in after about
five minutes at a cools you down.
And psychopaths,
it doesn't happen.
It stays on.
It stays on a hard boil a.
But even though he could control it,
you're still angry.
You can stay angry for extremely long
periods of time.
And um,
and that is sort of set up in utero
because those areas of the brain that
respond to serotonin are altered by
these so called warrior gene,
so they don't respond when you get
older,
when the serotonin would have made you
calm.
And so psychopath will get very angry,
but they'll stay angry.
And in the case of,
of mine,
I what I,
what I told them,
the two of the psychiatrists were very
close to me.
I said,
well,
when I get mad,
I don't show it to anybody.
I said,
I could be furious at you.
You would never know it.
I show no anger whatsoever at don't show
anxious anxiety to them.
I said,
first of all,
you'll never know.
And I said,
I could sit on it for a year or two or
three or five,
but I'll get you.
And I always do.
And they don't know where it's coming
from.
They can't tie it to the event.
And that comes out of nowhere and
something dramatic happens in their
life.
But I'm very careful,
uh,
almost pristine about it.
That's a fair response.
It's a proportional response.
So if somebody does something,
you can do a lot,
you know,
I could,
you could say anything to me and I won't
get mad.
Really.
I'm not at those things.
Don't get me mad.
Someone's trying to get me.
It's like another cycle path or another,
you know,
somebodies trying to mess with me.
Uh,
I,
I have a high threshold.
So many things really.
Don't get me mad.
You could just about,
do anything.
I'm pretty cool that way,
but you've really do.
Then I always get even and it in it and
I'll make sure it's the same sort of
intensity that they,
their,
their initial damage and I said I can
stay cool and it'll happen in these.
Still look around.
They don't what happened with their job,
what happened with their family,
what happened?
They'll they won't know.
And they both said that psychopath.
That's exactly it.
And so some of the,
you know,
people at the bbc and in Australia who I
had talked to some science writers this.
So that's what dexter is.
So,
and I really,
when I saw dexter,
I absolutely understood it because he
was being fair,
being fair to the universe and the world
of ethics of the universe.
He was absolutely fair.
A morality wise,
not so much,
but I,
I could really understand that behavior.
One of the surprises for me,
uh,
about starting about six years ago and
for the few years until now when I said,
you know,
there's something is really wrong that I
was not cognizant of.
I didn't know I had this.
And,
and,
uh,
even though other people did,
they didn't,
they won't tell you,
you know,
once I asked,
they said,
of course you're that.
But so people protect people close to
them.
They protect our tormentors.
It's kind of a,
a family,
stockholm effect.
And I've interviewed some really
dangerous bad guys in prison and who,
they'll protect theIr tormentors.
And so the left hands,
you,
you won't find this out,
but you have to ask and you have to say,
I'm not going to get even with you,
just telling me the truth and you say it
to enough people that they know you're
doing it.
Then you'll,
you'll find that out.
So when that happened,
and I started to think,
I said,
well,
how can I change this without anybody
knowing?
So I just started with my wife a couple
of years ago.
I started and I,
every time I was about to do something
with her,
you know,
we're pouring a glass of wine or eating
or going to a show,
anything I would stop for one moment
and,
and I would say,
what are you doing?
And I noticed that every time I was
about to do something with her,
it was the absolutely the most selfish
thing.
And for regular behavior it's like you
pour yourself the wine first,
you serve yourself first,
you try to get out of some duties even
though you'd make it look like you're,
you know,
you're cleaning up.
But also it gets worse than that.
So you know,
for bIrthdays or you know,
if there was a big party going on and
there was a death in the family,
an uncle or an aunt,
and I thought there's another party,
I would make up an excuse to go to the
party.
I would just blow off those things and,
but it would extend it to everything I
was doing,
you know,
and even to the people who were close to
me to not only family,
uh,
and,
and I noticed that and I said,
geez,
I said everything I'm doing is maximally
like selfish,
so I have to slow myself down now and
try to just do the correct thing.
They're very small.
You have to start small because that's
where you have to start because the
other stuff is true.
Traumatic.
They really try to change yourself.
But I've tried doing this and I noticed
that and I didn't tell her I was doing
this and other people and they said,
I like your behavior and it's,
you're,
you're different.
Why?
What happened?
And I told them and I said,
I said,
you know,
I don't really mean it.
And they said,
my wife,
she goes,
I don't care.
You just treating me better.
And I went,
I couldn't believe it.
I thought,
see,
I had taken that whole thing of empathy,
meaning beyond what people behaviorally
are asking for and everybody in my life,
they said,
who knows what people's motivations are?
If you're treating me well,
it means you're trying and that's all
that matters.
This blew me away and I just,
I really still don't understand it,
but I keep trying to do that.
Right?
And so I.
But I have to stop myself and in each
one of these,
anytime I do something,
so what's the right thing to do?
And when you do that,
you're somebody like me.
You realize your whole day is spent
thousands of times during the most
selfish thing.